-Timothée Chalamet.
Always good to see you, buddy.
Thank you so much
for coming back to our show.
-Thanks for having me back.
-You got such a great energy.
Every time I run into you,
you're always --
-And you were surprised
backstage, right?
-Yeah, I was.
-I scared Jimmy backstage.
Because he knocked on my door,
I went "Aaaah!"
[ Laughter ]
-You were right behind the door.
Normally, I knock on the door,
and then, open it up
and walk into the dressing room.
I opened up, but you --
you were right there
and jumped out at me, yeah.
-I had been waiting.
I was there.
-I wanted --
How long were you waiting for?
-For three hours.
[ Laughter ]
-I want to ask you
about this photo here,
because we've had Kim Kardashian
on the show and Pete Davidson,
and they were
talking about this night.
There's a picture of you guys
out to dinner with Kid Cudi
and Kanye West.
-Okay. So, Kid Cudi
is my favorite artist ever.
I wouldn't be acting
without him.
I wouldn't pursue
this crazy career,
and I just text him one morning,
his birthday, and he said,
"Oh, come to dinner tonight."
I did not know that was
what I was walking into.
Which was awesome
but was surreal.
Had to go in the bathroom,
send a couple of texts,
like, you know...
[ Laughter ]
-So, you thought you were
going to dinner with Kid Cudi.
-Yeah, which would've
already been very surreal.
Because that's a --
You know, whenever I'm, like,
trying to have a good time,
but I'm also, like, coming off
weird, like right now.
-No, no, no, no, no.
[ Laughter ]
You're coming off
totally normal and fun.
So, you get there
and Pete Davidson's there.
Do you know Pete?
-Yeah, Pete's great.
He's a fellow New Yorker.
Just did a movie
with my sister, actually."
-Oh, really?
-Yeah, Judd Apatow movie.
-No way.
-Yes.
-So, it's you,
Pete, and Kid Cudi.
And then, how do you know
if Kim and Kanye are coming?
-Well, I got there,
and I had sneaking suspicion,
but they weren't -- there was
not enough seats for everyone,
so I thought
I was gonna be safe.
And then --
Not safe, but it was.
[ Laughter ]
And then, we're hanging out,
and then it feels like
there's an earthquake
in the restaurant,
but it was -- it was --
it was, like, epic.
You know, you can feel the,
like --
-The energy shift.
-You turn around,
and I was like, "Holy [bleep]"
You know, 'cause, like,
I feel like I'm in this now
a little bit.
But then, I'm like, "I can't --
I can't feel, like --
I feel like too much
of a fraud or something."
So, I'm like,
"What?! This is nuts." Yeah.
-That you were sitting with
Kid Cudi and Kanye?
Or Kim or what?
-All of them, man.
I'm not -- I'm not --
-And where was this? What room?
-Well, that's in a back room
at that point.
You know,
I went to the bathroom.
Seriously, I sent a text
to two friends, and my words,
like, "Does this make sense?"
And they were like,
"Man, 16-year-old you
would slap the [bleep]
out of you.
Go back to the table."
[ Laughter ]
And I went to the table,
and then, like --
And then, it was fun.
It was a good time.
And then, you have enough, like,
random whatever
they have on the table,
and then you forget about
all of it, anyway.
-Yeah, exactly.
It's fun, yeah.
-Now don't do that.
It's not a healthy way
to deal with it,
but in that moment, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-With 16-year-old you,
what would you be doing,
if not acting?
-I'm not good at anything else.
That's the only thing
I'm, like, decent at.
I mean, like, my mom's
a dance teacher,
so maybe something in the arts,
maybe, like,
dancing or something.
-'Cause I do have a photo of you
in a dance -- a dance thing.
It's pretty awesome.
-That's --
This is you at
the National Dance Institute.
This is you as Cupid.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
I mean,
I think you have a future.
Timothée.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on!
How cute is that?
You got good form, buddy.
What do you remember about this?
-I remember absolutely nothing.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on!
-That's not even me!
-Come on. Come on.
No, it's not even you.
Just a random kid, yeah.
-They just brought that up.
No, that was surreal.
That's actually
at my high school
that I went to, eventually,
so the first time I was
on that stage was at
the high school I went to.
And nobody
would care about that,
but that's something I remember.
-No, people do care about that.
I saw somewhere,
we were reading up on you,
and it said on your résumé,
your acting résumé,
you put things on there like --
besides acting --
skills that you could do.
-Yes.
-One of them, I think,
was dance.
Maybe one of them was chess,
I want to say?
-It was random.
My mom used to fill out
my résumé,
so they have special skills,
and you go in for auditions.
-Chess. [ Laughs ]
-Like, no casting director's
gonna be like,
"This kid plays chess!
Let's put him in a movie."
[ Laughter ]
-"Can you fake chess?"
-But it was a lot.
It was like, chess, bike riding,
you know, swimming.
Like normal [bleep]
Normal things.
Sorry, sorry.
-You can't say that word.
-Sorry, sorry, sorry.
-Do you know how much money
you're costing NBC right now?
Oh, my God.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's gonna hurt
the opening weekend.
Trust me, buddy.
-No!
-No, no.
But we saw that on there.
And one of the things
that's on there was juggling.
-Juggling, yeah.
I used to be able to know --
Well, maybe, I --
But you have juggling balls
right here?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm just saying...
Now, I don't know anything.
I can't do --
I can't do it at all.
I'm terrible.
I really have no clue.
Can you juggle?
-Let's take a shot. Okay.
-Yeah, it's Timothée Chalamet
juggling.
Giving it a shot.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right.
-Come on, bud!
Come on, dude.
You already had your spot.
It's like a talent show here.
-Like a talent show.
-It's like a talent show.
-What would your juggling
equivalent be?
-What, do I just?
-Like special skill,
weird, random thing.
-Oh, I have the worst special --
I don't know
what my special skills was.
My special skill was --
I guess I do impressions.
That was my --
-Well, dude, you're the host --
This is amazing.
-I know, but if I'm gonna be
in a movie,
you don't need somebody
who's gonna do impressions.
-"Fever Pitch."
Who's seen "Fever Pitch" here?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes, no.
-Stop it!
-No, I'm not gonna
get into anything.